avec le retour des beaux jours finit la
grisaille des villes les petites plantes
jouent des coudes et pousse les murs ou
plutôt se saisissent des moindre
hésitations du macadam
elles reçoivent même parfois un petit
coup de pouce du destin et c'est à
grands coups de marteau tonitruant qu'on
se prépare à les recevoir jusqu'à sur le
bord de notre toile à fleur de trottoir
c'est justement le nom choisi par la
ville de tours pour son opération de
fleurissement
le principe est simple les habitants
s'inscrivent et n'ont plus qu'à attendre
le passage du service des parcs et
jardins qui fournissent gracieusement
terre plantes et graines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment pour une plante survivre dans
ces petits espaces citadin est un sport
un peu xtreme tout ne conviennent pas et
les plantes choisies appartiennent à des
variétés très résistante
si on peut voir un magnifique arbustes
un frémaux dans l'indre ont qui fleurit
la à partir de maintenant donc avril
une bonne partie une bonne partie mais
parfois ils refleurit même en fait en
arrière saison donc sanaa buste a pâli
ces conseils un petit peu sur
l'extérieur et se place naturellement on
a beaucoup de choses aussi des sauges de
type grammy sage vivaces donc qui des
saumons des roses on a des bleus
également donc céder soit très très
résistante très fleurie flair qui elles
vont fuir vraiment jusqu'au jusqu'aux
gelées très tard en saison on recommande
donc aux citoyens une fois qu'ils
avaient qu'on a fait les plantations
avec lui c'est surtout quand même de
bien arrosée la première année ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose de primordial
pour que les plantes et le système
racinaire est vraiment le temps de
s'installer
on leur demande également de désherber
quand même régulièrement à la main pour
que les plantes étant également
s'installer et prendre leur masse
foliaire d'en haut niveau de la fosse là
là on a vu que les gens même mis un
petit paillage naturel donc c'est encore
c'est encore plus sympa et en général on
le recommande une à deux fois par an de
mettre un engrais organique au niveau du
haut niveau du prix les plantes pour les
réconforter et favoriser la pousse
allez à vos binettes et vous ne pourrez
plus jamais dire que vous n'avez pas la
main verte
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à